behold the foundation of our universe
the ideas that govern the microscopic
world its quantum field theory time this
episode was supported by Skillshare hey
crazies I know you've wanted quantum
field theory for a while now well it's
finally time but let's ease into this
with a closer look at light we've got
two different models for light the e/m
wave model and the photon particle model
both of which seemed pretty unconnected
spoiler alert they're not having ideas
be separate is great when you're trying
to be practical but deeper understanding
comes from seeing how things are the
same even though Henry from
minutephysics has called me pedantic for
this philosophy I'm gonna stand by it
anyway neither of these models is part
of the other like I said they seem
unconnected the only possibility is that
there's a deeper idea that explains both
of them that deeper idea is the quantum
field but let's ask a simpler question
first what is a field I did a video on
this before but that was back in the
early days so let's go over this again a
field is a quantity or measurement
assigned to all points in space that's
it nothing more nothing less
but quantities come in many different
varieties kind of like my clones there
are scalar quantities which are just
single numbers a scalar field would be
something like voltage or electric
potential a single number assigned to
every point in space there are also
vector quantities which are numbers with
Direction a vector field would be
something like an electric field a
number and arrow assigned to every point
in space there are even tensor
quantities with many levels of detail a
tensor field would be something like the
riemann space-time curvature a
collection of 256 numbers assigned to
each event in space-time light is called
an electromagnetic wave because it's a
wave in the electromagnetic field when I
show you a wave like this the blue and
orange arrows don't have a size in space
only the white line does the arrows are
measured in whatever units are
appropriate for the field a field that
existed before the wave passed through
I just always kept the picture simpler
by not showing you the field every field
has an equilibrium in the middle of
empty space with nothing around the
equilibrium for the e/m field is zero
everywhere when the light passes through
the field is disturbed and those numbers
change after the light passes through
the field returns to normal the point of
trying to make is that zero values don't
mean the field isn't there zero is still
something the field is always there well
at least not paper I mean the physical
existence of a field is still up for
debate
so is that electromagnetic field a
quantum field man not really at least
not the one I just showed you oh come to
think of it that electromagnetic field
is actually two fields a blue arrow for
the electric field and an orange arrow
for the magnetic field but when we talk
about them we group them together as one
thing you might say we unify them that's
what a unified theory is showing that
two different things are just different
parts of the same thing in this case the
electromagnetic field this is a tensor
that has electric parts and magnetic
parts instead of having two different
vector fields we just have one tensor
field but tensors aren't always very
convenient hmm let's take us one step
deeper the electrical magnetic vector
fields can be written as changes in
electric and magnetic potentials that
brings our tensor of 16 numbers down to
just a vector of four it contains all
the same information and honestly it's
much closer to reality wait a minute
potential is almost potential energies I
think we're onto something here we've
stepped down from the electromagnetic
field to an energy field energy is
something quantum particles can have a
quantum field is just a field of quantum
properties a quantum measurement like
energy assigned to every point in space
but this is where things get a little
wonky quantum properties are intertwined
with each other through the wavefunction
and if we imagine that quantum
properties are part of fundamental
fields then they're no longer attached
to particles there are 17 different
types of particles with unique
properties some of those properties are
fixed others likes
orientation have some wiggle room if we
start treating their properties as
fields instead then we're gonna need
like a hundreds of fields so many fields
my brain hurts
oh all right maybe we can group them
together like we did for the e/m field
let's focus on some basic quantum
numbers spin electric charge and color
charge color charge is how we tell
gluons apart from photons commenters if
we grew up using those properties the
field count drops way down different
spins and charges require separate
fields so we've got six leptons six
quarks each with three possible color
charges eight color charge combinations
four gluons yep I'll separate one photon
three weak bosons and one Higgs if each
one gets its own field that's a grand
total of 37 fields which is the best we
can do without a semester-long course in
particle physics wait then what's a
particle perfect timing
you're like my best clone ever I'm so
proud of you really so the fields exist
everywhere across all space and time but
that doesn't mean particles are
everywhere there's only a particle when
a quantum field gets excited
for example this is the photon field
with no photons in sight here an empty
space the field energy hovers around
zero which is some quantum uncertainty
keeping it from being exactly zero it's
called the vacuum State
the ground state of the field suddenly
an electron and a positron crash into
each other they annihilate and their
energy is added to the photon field the
result is two photons two nonzero places
in the photon field but then the same
thing can be said about the electron and
the positron they were just places in
the electron field with an energy
hovering above zero and their
interaction shoved their energy into a
different field the photon field it's
just energy moving from one field to
another
welcome to quantum electrodynamics the
study of how the electron field and the
photon field interact it's an example of
something called a quantum field theory
a model that governs how quantum fields
interact so to summarize a quantum field
is a set of quantum properties assigned
to every point in space each one
existing alongside the others allowing
them to interact and any energy in a
field higher than its vacuum state will
be seen as a particle carrying the
properties of that field as usual if you
have any questions please ask in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us and until
next time remember it's okay to be a
little crazy if you're like me and you
like learning new skills and also like
online video you might want to try out
Skillshare there are over 17,000 video
courses available for aspiring creators
including many on animating and After
Effects the software I use in my own
videos if you want to learn how to make
animations as cool-looking as the ones
in this video you might want to check
out the ultimate guide to shape layers
and After Effects by Jake Bartlett shape
layers are extremely powerful tools and
After Effects if you know how to use
them techniques I learned from the
ultimate guide to shape layers made my
fancy particle chart possible an annual
membership to Skillshare is less than
$10 a month but if you sign up in
January 2018 using the link in the
doobly-doo you'll get three months $4.99
it's so if you're interested check it
out by the way I meant it when I said
photons don't experience spacer time in
our frame of reference they do of course
but they don't in their own for a photon
all of space is one point and all of
time is one moment in on that note
thanks for watching
[Music]